Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I no longer believe in any other revolution, said Richard Wagner, save that which begins with the burning down of Paris. A comment that speaks volumes about the outsized role that the French capital has played in the imaginings, not just of the French themselves, but of the entire world. And today's episode is the first episode of The Rest is History that we're devoting to the history of an entire city. And Dominic Zanbroek with me. It's got to be Paris, hasn't it, really? I suppose so. I think Paris has played this emblematic role, hasn't it, in the world's imagination for the best part of, well, certainly maybe a thousand years um i actually don't like paris at all tom um as our twitter followers will know yes they do
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。理查德·瓦格纳曾说：“我不再相信任何其他的革命，除了那场以烧毁巴黎为开端的革命。”这句话充分说明了法国首都不仅在法国人自己的想象中，而且在全世界的想象中都占据着举足轻重的地位。今天的节目是《历史的余烬》首次将一整集献给一座城市的历史。多米尼克·桑布鲁克（Dominic Zanbroek）也和我在一起。非巴黎莫属，对吧？我想是的。我认为在过去的大部分时间里——当然至少有一千年——巴黎在世界的想象中一直扮演着这种具有象征意义的角色。实际上我一点也不喜欢巴黎，汤姆。正如我们的推特粉丝所知，是的，他们知道。
because because um every week obviously when we do an episode we ask for questions yeah so mine very francophile i i that's you know we will be tracing the surprise me we will be tracing the glories beauties wonders and terrors that have marked 2,000 years of the City of Light. That was me. Yeah. Have you got mine there as well? The City of Light, or the most overrated city on earth, a wash in dog excrement where you often see people urinating in the streets.
因为……因为显然每周我们做节目时都会征集问题，对，所以我的观点非常法兰非勒。那你知道的，我们将追溯……惊艳到我吧……我们将追溯见证了光之城两千年历史的光辉、美丽、奇迹与恐怖。那个人是我。对。你那儿也有我的问题吗？光之城，或者说地球上被高估得最厉害的城市，这里到处都是狗屎，你经常能看到人们在街头随地小便。
I had the worst bout of food poisoning of my life in Paris, incidentally. You did my voice perfectly. You did my voice perfectly, John. John Bull speaks. I had scallops on Valentine's Day with my wife, and we both got hideously ill. And that, to me, that was like the nail in the coffin of the City of Light.
顺便说一句，我在巴黎遭遇了这辈子最严重的一次食物中毒。你把我的声音模仿得惟妙惟肖。你把我的声音模仿得太完美了，约翰。约翰·布尔（John Bull）发话了。我和妻子在情人节吃了一份扇贝，结果两个人都病得惨不忍睹。对我而言，这就好比是给光之城钉上了棺材板。
I haven't been back, actually. Never been back. That's what comes of going abroad, though, isn't it? Well, people used to take tins of baked beans, didn't they? A terrible warning. Yes. Thank goodness, then. though isn't it well people used to terrible bay beans didn't they a terrible warning yes thank goodness then thank goodness that as well as the john bull of chipping norton we have our first french guest agnes poirier um well-known journalist well-known commentator who has um familiar to both French and to British listeners,
其实我再也没去过。从来没再去过。不过，这就是去国外旅游的下场，对吧？人们以前都会随身带着一罐罐的烘豆，不是吗？真是一个可怕的警告。没错。谢天谢地，既然如此。不过不是这样的吗？人们以前都会带上可怕的……烘豆，不是吗？一个可怕的警告。是的，谢天谢地，那么，除了奇平诺顿（Chipping Norton）的约翰·布尔之外，谢天谢地，我们迎来了第一位法国嘉宾阿涅斯·普瓦里耶（Agnes Poirier），她是一位知名记者、知名评论员……
but also has written two fantastic books on the history of Paris, Left Bank, Art, Passion and the Rebirth of Paris, 1940 to 1950. And that's a really fabulous book because that 1940 to 1950, you get the Second World War and then you get the recovery from the Second World War. And that's kind of unusual way of doing it. And then, Agnes, Notre Dame, the soul of France, which obviously you wrote in the aftermath of the terrible fire that swept the great cathedral. And you begin the book very movingly with an account of, you know, you watched the fire, you live right next to the
法国和英国的听众对她都很熟悉，她还写了两本关于巴黎历史的精彩著作：《左岸：1940-1950年的艺术、激情与巴黎重生》（Left Bank, Art, Passion and the Rebirth of Paris, 1940 to 1950）。这是一本非常棒的书，因为在1940年至1950年期间，你经历第二次世界大战，然后经历从二战中的恢复。这是一种比较不寻常的写作方式。然后，阿涅斯，还有《巴黎圣母院：法国的灵魂》（Notre Dame, the soul of France），显然你是在那场席卷了大教堂的可怕火灾之后写下了这本书。你在书中以非常感人的方式开篇，讲述了你目睹火灾的过程，你刚好住在……
cathedral itself. And that was something, the thought that Notre Dame might be lost was something that people in Paris, people in France obviously found incredibly upsetting, but also people around the world. And I wonder, why do you think it had the impact that it did, the thought that Notre Dame might be lost? Well, I mean, we have to go back on that night, 15th of April 2019, and I happened to be in Paris. Strangely, I was preparing to comment on an address that President Macron was going to do after the unrest of the Yellow Vests, the Gilets Jaunes. And it was a beautiful, beautiful day. And when in Paris Paris I'm lucky to live right opposite on the left bank with a wonderful view on the south rose window and 7 p.m I see this huge smoke yellow smoke and clouds through the kitchen window and so I rush down on the quay, on the river, because it could only come from what is opposite, that is to say, Notre Dame.
大教堂旁边。这是一个重大的事件，巴黎人、法国人显然对巴黎圣母院可能会消失的想法感到无比痛心，全世界的人也是如此。我想知道，为什么你认为巴黎圣母院可能会消失这种想法会产生如此巨大的影响？嗯，我的意思是，我们必须回到那个夜晚，2019年4月15日，当时我恰好在巴黎。很巧的是，我正准备评论马克龙总统在“黄背心”骚动之后将要发表的一场演讲。那是一个非常非常美好的日子。在巴黎时，我很幸运能住在左岸的正对面，从厨房的窗户可以看到南侧的玫瑰窗，晚上7点钟，我看到巨大的烟雾、黄色的浓烟和云团，所以我立刻冲到河边的码头，因为这只能来自对面的建筑，也就是巴黎圣母院。
And that was the beginning of a very dramatic evening. And it's very strange because there were two things happening at the same time. You're a French person or a Parisian, and you feel this ontological shock and you're profoundly upset, but you don't exactly know why. Of course, it's a gem of Gothic architecture. She's been with us in Notre Dame for more than 850 years,
那是这个充满戏剧性的夜晚的开始。这非常奇怪，因为当时有两件事同时发生。作为一个法国人或巴黎人，你会感受到这种本体论的冲击，并感到深深的痛苦，但你又说不清楚原因。当然，它是哥特式建筑的瑰宝。巴黎圣母院陪伴了我们超过850年，
achievement of humankind, but it went much further than that. And that's why, actually, I wanted to write the book. I wanted to understand my own feelings. And second shock is to see that the whole world is watching with us those images and feel the same thing. And because I've got to commence, that's my daily job to, you know, every time there's something happening in France or in Paris, I get calls from
这是人类的伟大成就，但它的意义远不止于此。这也是我其实想写这本书的原因。我想了解我自己的感受。而第二个震惊则是看到全世界都在和我们一起注视着这些画面，并感同身受。因为我需要做评论，这是我的日常工作，你知道的，每当法国或巴黎发生什么事时，我就会接到来自……
all over the world and I need to find words immediately to explain what's going on. And I had people in tears in TV studios and radio studios in Sydney, in Singapore, in Beijing, name it, all over the world. And some of them, TV presenters in tears saying, and yes, I've never been to France, but I know Notre Dame. I'm in tears. Explain why I felt like this. And so suddenly there was a hadn't set foot in the cathedral in 15 years. I'm not
全世界各地的电话，我必须立刻找到词汇来解释发生了什么。悉尼、新加坡、北京，数都数不过来的世界各地的电视演播室和广播演播室里，有的人甚至潸然泪下。其中一些电视节目主持人流着泪说：“阿涅斯，我从来没去过法国，但我知道巴黎圣母院。我哭了。请解释一下为什么我有这种感觉。”所以突然之间……有15年没踏入过大教堂了。我不是……
a practicing Catholic, I'm not religious. So the religious dimension, you know, couldn't tell the whole story. And so we're really at the heart, if you'd like, of your podcast in, you know, why Paris? Of course, Paris had to be the first uh podcast you would dedicate to a city because this is uh the epitome of uh the city and i think it's been going on for a thousand years and what do you think it means then if you can boil it down i mean that's obviously we're meant to be doing that in an hour but if you can boil it down in sort of three lines or so, what is it that Paris represents, do you think? It depends, you know, if we're starting in the 12th century, for instance, we could, especially if we're talking about Notre Dame,
一个虔诚的天主教徒，我没有宗教信仰。所以宗教层面，你知道的，并不能说明全部问题。所以我们真的触及了你们播客的核心，你知道的，为什么是巴黎？当然，巴黎必须成为你们献给的第一座城市……播客，因为这是……城市的缩影，而且我认为这种情况已经持续了一千年。如果你把它浓缩一下，你认为它意味着什么？我的意思是，我们本来就应该在一小时内完成这个，但如果你能把它浓缩成大约三行左右，你认为巴黎代表了什么？这取决于，你知道的，如果我们从12世纪开始，举个例子，我们可以，特别是如果我们谈论的是巴黎圣母院，
but we could also be slightly more modern or contemporary in the sense that I think for people today, they get their idea of Paris because Paris is as much an idea than a reality. Yeah. But you know what's interesting though? You talk about the medieval and the modern, but even in antiquity, so there's a comment by Julian the Apostate, who was the nephew of Constantine the Great. And he says, of Paris, he calls it Lutetia, which is the Roman name, and he calls it my beloved Lutetia. So even in the Roman period, there was clearly something about it that gave it this kind of sense. And perhaps, I don't know what it is. Perhaps it's just the positioning of it on the Seine.
但我们也可以更现代或当代一些，因为我认为对于今天的人们来说，他们对巴黎的看法很大程度上是因为巴黎既是一个观念，也是一种现实。对。但你知道有趣的是什么吗？你谈到了中世纪和现代，但即使在古代，比如背教者尤利安（Julian the Apostate）——他是君士坦丁大帝的侄子——就曾对巴黎做出过评价。他称巴黎为“卢泰西亚”（Lutetia），这是罗马时期的名字，他称之为“我挚爱的卢泰西亚”。所以即使在罗马时期，它显然也有某种特质，赋予了它这种感觉。也许，我不知道那是什么。也许只是它在塞纳河畔的地理位置。
Perhaps it's just kind of the drama of its positioning. I don't know. There's lots of cities on rivers. I mean, there must be something more than that. Yeah. Clearly, I mean, it's an important Roman city. Its name, Paris, comes from the local tribe, the Parisi. It survives the fall of Rome. Kings in paris the frankish kings are
也许仅仅是它地理位置所带来的戏剧性。我不知道。河边的城市有很多。我的意思是，一定还有比这更多的原因。是的，很显然，它是一座重要的罗马城市。它的名字“巴黎”（Paris），来自于当地的一个部落——巴黎西族（Parisi）。它在罗马灭亡后幸存了下来。巴黎的国王们——法兰克国王们——
building amphitheaters as late as the sixth century it's kind of amazing so in a sense there's a kind of degree of continuity much greater than you get say in the history of london where there really is a kind of meltdown um and then it emerges again as the main city of the of what becomes the french royal family so that's really the key isn't it and yes that it's it's it's a royal city from the beginning yes it is and actually it's interesting when i say it's the idea as it's as much an idea than a reality in the 12th century look at cities all around europe um you know london has inhabitants. Actually, the most populous cities are found in the Flanders and in northern Italy. Venice and Milan have 200,000 inhabitants, which is enormous. But Paris has almost 300,000 inhabitants. And while cities usually perform one role, for instance, you know,
直到6世纪还在建造圆形剧场，这真是令人难以置信。从某种意义上说，这里存在着一种连续性，其程度远大于伦敦的历史，伦敦的历史确实经历过某种崩溃，然后它又作为后来成为法国王室的主城重新崛起。所以这才是关键所在，不是吗，阿涅斯？它从一开始就是一座王室城市。是的，确实如此。实际上很有趣，当我说它既是一个观念，也是一种现实时，在12世纪，看看欧洲各地的城市……你知道的，伦敦有居民。实际上，人口最多的城市在法兰德斯和意大利北部。威尼斯和米兰拥有20万居民，这非常庞大。但巴黎拥有近30万居民。通常城市只发挥一种作用，比如说，
Ghent, for instance, is a commercial city, or Venice is a commercial city, and Bologna is a university city. Well, Paris performs all the roles. It's a university city, it's a royal city, it's the bishop's city, it's also the merchant city. And that time, when actually Notre Dame, it's not a surprise, was built, you know, between, let's say, 1150 and the end of the 14th century, the end of the 13th century, sorry, Paris will live through 150 years of continuous growth. Imagine that. It's never happened since.
根特是一座商业城市，或者威尼斯是一座商业城市，博洛尼亚是一座大学城市。然而，巴黎发挥了所有的作用。它是一座大学城市，是一座王室城市，是一座主教城市，也是一座商业城市。在那个时期，巴黎圣母院的建造——这毫不令人意外——大约在1150年到14世纪末、13世纪末之间，巴黎将经历150年的持续增长。想象一下。此后再也没有发生过。
It's a dream, you know, because we're talking about intellectual expansion, artistic, economic. It's a huge economic boom. And here you are, you know, this gem of a Gothic masterpiece springing from the very heart, the Île de la Cité. And at the time, we're talking about 10,000 inhabitants just there. Today, there are only, what, not even 900. And it's the bustle of a city. It's, you know, the life. The rich live next to the poor and destitute and the narrow lanes. I mean, when I had to research that medieval Ile de la Cité, it was extraordinary because it's this, you know, if I was a chemist, I would talk about the precipitate of life. You know, it's there.
这简直像个梦，你知道的，因为我们在谈论智识的扩张、艺术的扩张、经济的扩张。这是一个巨大的经济繁荣期。而就在这里，哥特式杰作中的这颗明珠从其核心——西岱岛（Île de la Cité）破土而出。在当时，我们说那里仅有1万名居民。而今天，那里只有不到900人。这是一座城市的喧嚣，是生活。富人与穷人和赤贫者比邻而居，挤在狭窄的小巷里。我的意思是，当我不得不研究中世纪的西岱岛时，这是非同寻常的，因为它是……如果我是个化学家，我会谈论生命的沉淀物。你知道的，它就在那里。
And it's coming from all over Europe, isn't it? I mean, that's the other thing, that right from the beginning, Paris is a magnet for people, not just from France, but from across Europe. And they're going to the university. And even in the Middle Ages, Paris is famous for its intellectuals. Well, yes. Dominic's pulling a face. That's just my natural resting face, Dom. Maybe it's a knee-jerk thing when I hear the word intellectuals. You reach for your gun yeah but the students the students were flocking to the university of paris
而且它吸引着全欧洲的人，不是吗？我的意思是，这是另一回事，从一开始，巴黎就是一块磁铁，吸引着不仅来自法国，而且来自全欧洲的人们。他们去大学求学。甚至在中世纪，巴黎就以其知识分子而闻名。嗯，是的。多米尼克正在做鬼脸。那只是我自然的放松表情，多姆。也许当我听到“知识分子”这个词时，这是一种膝跳反射。你会去摸你的枪，是的。但是学生们……学生们蜂拥至巴黎大学，
and already uh because obviously there were students uh you know religious students but already some very independent minded scholars and teachers um those you know young minds of Europe and setting up new schools and quite dissident schools right on the left bank and where would the students go and find lodgings well on the left bank it wasn't called the left bank, but because it was cheaper. And you think, okay, well, Jean-Paul Sartre, you know, you can, I mean, it started a thousand years. It begins with Abelard, I guess, who we did an episode on the top 10 eunuchs and Abelard appeared in that.
而且已经……因为显然有学生……你知道的，宗教学生，但已经有一些思想非常独立的学者和老师了……那些……欧洲的年轻头脑，他们在左岸建立新的学校，甚至是相当异类的学校。学生们会去哪里找住处呢？就在左岸。当时它还不叫左岸，但因为那里更便宜。你会想，好吧，让-保罗·萨特（Jean-Paul Sartre），你可以……我的意思是，这一切始于一千年以前。我想是从阿伯拉尔（Abelard）开始的，我们曾做过一期关于十大阉人的节目，阿伯拉尔就出现在其中。
And Agnes, at what point do you think, so cities often, their image is sort of created in competition with other cities. So London, the way we think of London, it's kind of wrapped up with the way we think of Paris. Paris is romantic and walking along the Seine, and London is businesslike and pragmatic and all this sort of stuff. At what point do you think Paris even noticed London?
阿涅斯，你认为在哪个时间点……城市往往是在与其他城市的竞争中塑造自己的形象的。所以伦敦，我们对伦敦的看法，它与我们对巴黎的看法交织在一起。巴黎是浪漫的，沿着塞纳河漫步；而伦敦是务实的、重商的，诸如此类。你认为巴黎是在哪个时间点开始注意到伦敦的？
Or was Paris defining itself against, I don't know, Rome or places in flanders or or other italian cities or whatever well it depends on you know what what period we're talking about because obviously um you know rome um well you know loomed heavily uh but also athens it's it's interesting there's a uh i'm just making a you know a huge a huge leap to the Belle Epoque, but there's an area of Paris called Pigalle, which I'm sure you know. And a lot of clubs or cafes at the Belle Epoque were called the New Babylon, the New Athens. And so London actually, you know, it's a 19th century comparison. I think this is when Paris, you know, when all the revolutionaries, the communards, you know, different, the exiles, basically, they would go to Belgium and they would go to Brussels and they would go to London. Also, perhaps the 18th century, Voltaire going to London. It's maybe the first time that London gets kind of promoted as an
还是说巴黎是在与……我不知道，与罗马、法兰德斯的城市、其他意大利城市或别的什么地方进行对比来定义自己的？嗯，这取决于我们谈论的是什么时期，因为很显然……你知道的，罗马……嗯，你知道的，有着沉重的阴影……但还有雅典。有趣的是……我只是做了一个……一个巨大的跨越，跨越到美好年代（Belle Epoque），巴黎有一个叫皮加勒（Pigalle）的地区，我相信你一定知道。在美好年代，许多俱乐部或咖啡馆被称为“新巴比伦”、“新雅典”。所以伦敦实际上……你知道的，这是一个19世纪的比较。我认为这是巴黎……当所有的革命者、公社社员、不同流派、基本上是流亡者前往比利时、布鲁塞尔和伦敦的时候。也许还有18世纪伏尔泰前往伦敦。这也许是伦敦第一次被当作一种……
alternative. Of course. And not only London, the fashion, what we call the Anglomania, probably started with Voltaire. And so we went through bouts and fads of thinking that everything english was fantastic but but think i mean going back to the middle ages and thinking the relationship between paris and london it london is absolutely subordinate and it's it's the fashions that you get in paris that determine what people wear in london and i guess that again i mean it's amazing you get kind of intellectuals amazing architecture and you get fashion right the way from the Middle Ages all the way through. And I guess that's the power of Paris as a kind of mythic place, isn't it? That actually, these myths are very, very old. And they're not even myths. They're kind of bread of circumstance. But it's amazing that Paris has had this kind of outsized role in the imaginings of Europeans right the way from the Middle Ages.
替代方案来宣传。当然。不仅是伦敦，这种时尚——我们称之为“狂英热”（Anglomania）——可能始于伏尔泰。因此，我们经历了一阵又一阵的风潮与狂热，认为所有英国的东西都是棒极了的。但是想想看……我的意思是，回到中世纪，思考巴黎和伦敦的关系，伦敦是绝对处于从属地位的，正是巴黎流行的时尚决定了伦敦人穿什么。我想这也是……令人惊叹的是，你拥有知识分子、惊人的建筑，而且从整个中世纪一直延续到现代，你都拥有时尚。我想这就是巴黎作为一种神圣之地的力量所在，不是吗？事实上，这些神话非常非常古老。它们甚至不是神话，它们某种程度上是环境的产物。但令人惊叹的是，从整个中世纪开始，巴黎在欧洲人的想象中就一直扮演着这种超乎寻常的角色。
And I think we should mention the French Revolution because for the people today, their knowledge of medieval time is not as great as the contemporary history. And we think, what are the clichés about Paris? It's May of the 68 events. It's mass protest, student protest with the black Polonex. You know, it's Derrida, it's Foucault. But before that, really, it's the French Revolution.
我认为我们应该提一下法国大革命，因为对于今天的人们来说，他们对中世纪的了解不如对当代历史的了解那么多。我们认为，关于巴黎的克里希（clichés）是什么？它是1968年5月的事件。它是大规模抗议，是穿着黑色高领衫的学生抗议。你知道，它是德里达（Derrida）、福柯（Foucault）。但在那之前，真正深刻的印记是法国大革命。
And when I said that Paris was an idea as much as a reality when your French citizen, a Parisian, fed on a motto which is liberté, égalité, fraternité, amener you never recover from it and actually it's almost a malediction as we call it it's almost a malediction, as we call it. It's almost a curse, really. Because do you know the Paris syndrome for the Japanese? They have such an incredible idea of supreme ideal, idealist idea of Paris, when they arrive in Paris, obviously they
当我刚才说巴黎既是一个观念也是一种现实时，作为一个法国公民、一个巴黎人，深受“自由、平等、博爱”（liberté, égalité, fraternité）这一座右铭的影响，你永远无法从中恢复过来。事实上，正如我们所说，这几乎是一种诅咒。这几乎是一种诅咒，真的。因为你知道日本人患上的“巴黎综合征”吗？他们对巴黎有着如此不可思议的、至高无上的理想主义想法，当他们到达巴黎时，显然他们……
are so disappointed, they feel sick. Like Dominic. Like Dominic, exactly. And so, because you can never reconcile the idea and the reality and i wish uh that so many people never set foot in paris because it's um the reality doesn't measure up to to the myth i i i wasn't just i i thought it was great i it met every expectation um when did you when did you go tom when did you first go how old are you um when did i first go i must have been about 20 I think and I I just felt incredibly depressed coming back to London thinking how much more beautiful Paris was um I was yeah I was really depressed about it I thought Paris
感到如此失望，甚至觉得恶心。就像多米尼克一样。就像多米尼克一样，没错。因此，因为你永远无法将观念与现实调和起来，我真希望……那么多人从未踏足巴黎，因为它的……现实根本配不上这个神话。我……我不仅仅是……我觉得它棒极了，它符合所有的期待……汤姆，你是什么时候去的？你第一次去的时候多大？我第一次去的时候大概20岁吧，我想，当时我回到伦敦时感到异常沮丧，觉得巴黎要美丽得多……我当时……我真的为此感到沮丧，我觉得巴黎……
was so amazing that I kind of looked at London and thought oh and what was it though was it the the sort of the boulevard and the 19th century I thought it was incredibly physically beautiful um yeah but it was just the excitement of it it was it was this kind of sense of that I was at the I was at the kind of beating heart of so much that had transformed and changed the world um it was it was kind of in the 80s and I think London felt a bit shabby in comparison well London was very shabby in the 80s but but it was the sense that you know i'm walking the streets where all these incredible people walked and it was you know i have an immense appetite for cliche and i've that appetite was hugely satisfied but it was yes it was the it was the weight of history i think um i mean we've got
是如此惊艳，以至于我看着伦敦，心想：哦……但那究竟是什么呢？是那种林荫大道和19世纪的建筑吗？我当时觉得它在物理层面上美得不可思议……是的，但那只是一种兴奋感。这是一种感觉，我觉得自己正处于……处于改变和重塑世界的那么多事物的跳动的心脏之中……那大约是在80年代，我觉得相比之下伦敦显得有点破旧。好吧，伦敦在80年代确实很破旧。但这是一种感觉：你知道的，我正在所有这些了不起的人物曾经走过的街道上行走，这……我对陈词滥调有着巨大的胃口，而那种胃口得到了极大的满足。但是的，这就是历史的份量，我想……我的意思是，我们有……
so on the on the theme of revolution we've got a question here from kane carlisle and he says wondering why paris is always linked to revolutionary figures. Thinking of figures such as Marx, Bakunin. What is it? Bakunin. How do you pronounce that? Bakunin. Yeah. So apologies to enthusiasts for revolutionary thinkers there.
顺着革命这个主题，我们这里有一个凯恩·卡莱尔（Kane Carlisle）提出的问题，他说：“想知道为什么巴黎总是与革命人物联系在一起。想到马克思、巴枯宁（Bakunin）这样的人物。这是为什么？巴枯宁。这个名字怎么读？巴枯宁。是的。”所以，向那些热衷于革命思想家的人致歉。
But also more modern revolutionary figures like Ayatollah Khomeini. Why do these people always set up shop there? Assuming it's not only due to legacy of the French Revolution. Ho Chi Minh was a pastry chef. Could I, I mean, just before we go back to the French Revolutionary period, just to go back a bit, I think, because I think one answer to that is that it is actually pre-revolutionary. So the parent of learning, who do you think described Paris as the parent of learning? It was Martin Luther, who you wouldn't have down as a Francophile.
还有一些更现代的革命人物，比如霍梅尼（Ayatollah Khomeini） ayatollah。为什么这些人总是在那里安营扎寨？假设这不仅仅是因为法国大革命的遗产。胡志明还当过糕点师呢。我能不能……在回到法国大革命时期之前，稍微往回倒一点？因为我认为，其中一个答案是它其实具有前革命的性质。教育之父……你认为是谁将巴黎描述为“教育之父”？那是马丁·路德（Martin Luther），你绝不会把他当作一个法兰非勒。
And the amazing thing about Paris is that both Ignatius Loyola, the guy who founds the Jesuits, and John Calvin, John Calvin, the great Protestant thinker, both studied at the same school. So even in the 16th century, although you tend to think of Germany
而巴黎的神奇之处在于，耶稣会的创始人伊格内修斯·罗耀拉（Ignatius Loyola）和新教伟大思想家约翰·加尔文（John Calvin），两人都在同一所学校学习过。因此，尽管你倾向于认为德国……
as the kind of the womb of the Reformation, it's all going on in Paris. And then, of course, you've got the literal slaughter of the streets with the massacre on St. Bartholomew's Day. So I think even the 16th century, you've got this sense of Paris as an absolute cauldron of intellectual, moral ferment, which I guess kind of percolates through. Paris is the intellectual capital as well as the fashion capital through the 17th, through the 18th century, which then is why the French Revolution comes as such a shock. It shouldn't really, because in a sense, it's kind of been brewing. But Agnes, James Beamish had a question about Paris's golden age.
是新教改革的腹地，但这一切其实都在巴黎发生。然后，当然，你还有圣巴托洛梅节大屠杀（St. Bartholomew's Day massacre）中街头血流成河的场面。所以我认为，甚至在16世纪，你就能感觉到巴黎是知识和道德发酵的绝对熔炉，我想这种氛围一直渗透下来。在17和18世纪，巴黎一直是知识之都和时尚之都，这也是为什么法国大革命会带来如此巨大的震撼。其实它本不该令人震惊，因为从某种意义上说，它一直在酝酿之中。不过，阿涅斯，詹姆斯·比米什（James Beamish）有一个关于巴黎黄金时代的问题。
Do you think the golden age was before the revolution or do you think it's more modern well i think the golden age i mean that's what i was describing when you think of the 12th century and the 13th century really um because we've never seen that expansion for such a long time uh we would dream of living 150 years of expansion, development in every single discipline. Yes. It hasn't been as good ever since. That's very depressing. And I'm not even a medievalist.
你认为黄金时代是在大革命之前，还是更现代一些？嗯，我认为黄金时代……我的意思是，这正是我刚才描述的，当你想到12世纪和13世纪时，真的是这样……因为我们从未见过如此长时间的扩张，我们做梦都希望能经历150年的全方位扩张和发展。是的。自那以后，就再也没有这么好过了。这太令人沮丧了。而且我甚至都不是一个中世纪史学者。
I think that's a great note on which to end the first half, that the whole history of Paris has been a sad decline since the 13th century. But perhaps in the second half, we could look at, I guess, what more traditionally would be seen as the golden age of Paris, which I guess would be the kind of the 19th century. And look at its 19th and 20th century history, because there's so much to talk about there. So we will see you back after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
我认为这是一个完美的上半场结束语：巴黎的整个历史自13世纪以来就是一个悲伤的衰落过程。但也许在下半场，我们可以看看……我想，传统上会被视为巴黎黄金时代的是什么，也就是19世纪。我们可以看看它的19和20世纪历史，因为那里有太多的话题可以探讨。所以我们休息后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和少许娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. Bienvenue, mes amis. We're talking about Paris with the French journalist, writer, and historian, Agnès Poirier. And we have... So, Agnès Poirier and we have, so Agnès the image of Paris to a lot of Anglo-Saxon listeners
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎来到我的朋友们。我们正在与法国记者、作家和历史学家阿涅斯·普瓦里耶（Agnès Poirier）一起谈论巴黎。我们有……所以，阿涅斯·普瓦里耶，我们有……所以，阿涅斯，在许多盎格鲁-撒克逊听众眼中，巴黎的形象……
now is a city that's constantly in revolution where basically people are always ripping up cobbles and throwing them at the police first of all is that justified and secondly is that do you think, is there a sense in which people are just constantly re-enacting the French Revolution and the events of 1789 and 1793, 1794? Again, every generation in Paris feels a kind of obligation almost to chuck stones at the police and sort of gird up for the guillotine.
现在是一座不断发生革命的城市，那里的人们基本上总是在撬开鹅卵石并把它们砸向警察。首先，这种看法是有依据的吗？其次，你认为这其中是否存在这样一种意味：人们只是在不断重演法国大革命以及1789年、1793年、1794年的事件？同样的，巴黎的每一代人都觉得自己有一种近乎强烈的义务，要向警察扔石头，并为断头台做好准备。
Well, you nailed it. It's impossible to be French and not to go through that rite of passage. We can't help it. It's ridiculous. And when you think of, you know, the last 200 and, you know, 40 years since the French Revolution, look at Britain.
嗯，你切中要害了。作为法国人，是不可能不经历这种成年礼的。我们对此无能为力。这太荒谬了。当你回想……自法国大革命以来的过去240年里，看看英国。
You know, Britain has been perfecting the art of croquet for that amount of time when France was actually going through 11 political changes and regime changes. And I'm talking, you know, from the empire to the first, second, third, fourth, fifth republic, the second empire, the commune. I would say even Vichy, but Vichy is not supposedly France, or at least that was the myth. But it's not Paris, is it? No, exactly. Precisely. But it's not even France. I mean, it's very convenient. We have a way with history and in a way that's how we could reconcile with each other after the war. But we now know, I mean, we owed it. And it was quite recently, actually, it was Jacques Chirac.
你知道，当法国实际上经历了11次政治变革和政权更迭时，英国却花了同样长的时间来完善板球运动。我所说的变革，你知道的，从第一帝国到第一、第二、第三、第四、第五共和国，第二帝国，再到公社。我甚至可以说还有维希（Vichy），但维希据称不是法国，或者至少那是神话。但那不是巴黎，对吗？不，完全正确。正是如此。但这甚至不是法国。我的意思是，这非常方便。我们对历史有自己的一套处理方式，某种程度上，这就是我们在战后能够彼此和解的方式。但我们现在知道，我的意思是，我们对此负有责任。而且其实是不久前，雅克·希拉克（Jacques Chirac）……
One of the very few good things he did as a president. He acknowledged the fact that Vichy France was also France. And yes, so it's turmoil all the time. And we've been talking about a sixth republic for the last 20 years now, as if it was going to solve our problems. And so, as you know, we thrive on division. We are unruly to an excess I would say
这是他担任总统期间为数不多的几件好事之一。他承认了维希法国也是法国这一事实。所以是的，这里一直动荡不安。过去20年来，我们一直在讨论第六共和国，就好像它能解决我们的问题一样。因此，正如你们所知，我们在分裂中滋养。我可以说，我们无法无天到了极点，
and clashing with the police is what you have to do and so there's always a demonstration that you can join and I was 14 when in 86 there was we didn't understand a thing I was obviously at the DC
与警察发生冲突是你必须要做的事，所以总有一场你可以加入的游行。1986年时我14岁……当时我们什么都不懂，我显然在DC……那是关于大学法律改革，我去游行了，闻到了催泪瓦斯的味道。实际上当时有一个学生被杀害了，所以第二天我意识到，这不仅仅是一项危险的运动。是的，正是在那个时候，我开始意识到抗议可能是危险的，而且这一切都具有高度的政治性。但关键是，政治……如果你是一个巴黎人，政治融入了你所做的每一件事，而且从很小的时候就开始了。我不记得自己什么时候没有过政治感，没有和父母一起去游行过，而且从那以后一直如此。作为伦敦的一名学生，我曾坐欧洲之星（Eurostar）去巴黎参加周末游行，然后再回来。哇，这真是全心投入。这绝对是全心投入。这不是全心投入。这是存在主义式的。当然是的。当然是的。你是巴黎人。
and it was the reform of the university law and I went marching and the smell of tear gas actually a student was killed so I realized the day after that it was not just a dangerous sport yes this is when I sort of realized that protest could be dangerous and it was all very political. But the thing is, politics, if you're a Parisian, politics in everything you do and from a very early age. I can't remember not feeling political, not going on the march with my parents and ever since. I used as a student in London, I would go on the Eurostar to go and march at the weekend in Paris and come back. Wow, that's commitment. That is commitment. It's not commitment. It's existential. Of course it is. Of course it is. You're Parisian.
这当然是存在主义的。是的，但这太累人了。好吧。所以纵观法国革命史的宏大脉络，我们已经讲了法国大革命。我们已经处理过这个了。我们已经完全把它梳理清楚了。任何人都不需要再讨论它了。再也不需要讨论了。我们已经搞定它了。至于拿破仑，我想我们会在稍后的某个时间点再讲。
Of course it's existential. Yes, but it's exhausting. Yes. Okay. So looking at the broad sweep of French revolutionary history, we've done the French Revolution. We've dealt with that already. We've completely sorted that out. It needs never be discussed by anybody again. It needs never be discussed again. We've nailed that. And Napoleon, I think we're going to do at some later point.
不过，在讲到法国大革命的那一集里，我提到我女儿最喜欢的电影是……《玛丽·安托瓦内特》（Marie Antoinette），但他们随后又看了另一部电影，当然就是……《悲惨世界》（Les Miserables）。不知道你们有没有看过，但里面有革命活动……多米尼克，你看过吗？看过，是的，我看过。好吧，那么《悲惨世界》对革命的描绘有多准确？但关键在于，这是一场非常微不足道的革命。在英国，这会被认为是一场大革命。但我认为《悲惨世界》中的起义实际上并不是一场成功的革命。没错。那大约是在1820年代的某个时候，对吧？
But could we, in the episode of the french revolution i mentioned how my my daughter's favorite film was um marie antoinette um but they then moved on to another film which was of course um les miserables don't know if you've seen it but it features um revolutionary activity um dominic have you seen it i have yeah i have seen it. Okay, so how accurate is the portrayal of the revolution in Les Miserables? But the thing about it is it's a very minor revolution. It's what in England would be considered a big revolution. But I think the uprising in Les Miserables is actually not a successful revolution. That's right. It's kind of in the 1820s sometime, isn't it?
那是不是1830年之前或1848年之前的一场起义？我记不清了。好吧，我只是问问，因为我女儿可能会听这个，所以我想让你给她们一个答案。既然阿涅斯没看过的话。好吧……我确信它是极其现实的。
Isn't it a sort of a pre-1830 or pre-1848? I can't remember. Well, I'm just asking because my daughter's to be listening to this, so I want you to give them the answer. Since Agnes hasn't seen it. Okay, well... I'm sure it's incredibly realistic.
这就是我的回答。而且他们都会唱歌。但这是其中的一部分……但实际上，《悲惨世界》完全且彻底地符合阿涅斯刚才所说的那种模式。确实如此。这种带有自我意识的法国大革命故事重演的模式，
That's my answer. And they all sing. But it's the part of... But actually Les Miserables completely and utterly conforms to what Agnes was talking about. It does. The pattern of the sort of self-conscious reproduction of the story of the French Revolution,
比如挥舞旗帜、筑起街垒。不过，我能告诉你们它还包含什么吗？这对我构建巴黎的想象至关重要。是的，它确实有罗素·克劳（Russell Crowe）。一个很棒很棒的歌手。但它还有什么呢？还有他们在下水道里奔跑。是的，有很多下水道……是的，有很多下水道，有很多地下墓穴和下水道……它们对我想象中的巴黎至关重要，那种大盗和侦探的感觉……维多克（Vidocq）——伟大的……伟大的警察局长，他后来创立了第一家侦探社——所以这也是其中的一部分……
the sort of waving the flag, the barricades. But can I tell you what it also has, which for me is a crucial part of my imagining? Yeah, it does have Russell Crowe. Great, great songster. But what it also has is them running through sewers. Yes, there's a lot of sewers yes there's a lot of sewers there's a lot of catacombs and sewers uh they're a crucial part of of my imagining of paris and the sense of you know master criminals and um detectives vidoc the great um the great police
我想这与那种感觉有些模糊地交织在一起：在巴黎，你永远无法完全确定谁是……罪犯会不会变成警察局长，反之亦然？同样地，皇帝会不会变成难民？会不会有一种持续的可能性，即一切都被彻底颠倒？你会不会觉得这也是巴黎历史的戏剧性和魅力所在？也许这也给你带来了存在主义式的头痛？是的，我同意。但你知道吗？就刚才我们所讨论的内容，再倒回一秒钟。
chief who then sets up the first detective agency so that's also a part of it um and i guess that that kind of blurs with the sense that in that in paris you're never entirely sure who's you know will will the criminal turn out to be the police chief or vice versa and likewise you know will the emperor turn out to be the refugee um will the there's the constant possibility that everything will be turned on its head? And would you agree that that's kind of part of the drama and the fascination of Parisian history? And perhaps also it gives you your existentialist headache? Yes, I would agree. But you know what? Just to go back one second on what we were saying.
法国大革命带给我们的观念——不仅是一个观念，因为它后来一直证明我们是正确的——是权力在于人民，而不在于民选代表或政府，这有点奇怪，在许多方面这完全不符合英国人的作风。在英国，当有一百万人走上街头时，这只是轶事。这不会改变政府或首相的任何决定，因为在英国，权力的合法性在于议会，而在法国则在于人民。所以我们知道我们拥有这种力量，我们只需要……你知道的，通常如果我们有数百万人在巴黎街头，
The thing with the French Revolution, it gave us the idea, and not only the idea, because it proved us right throughout, that the power lays with the people, not with the elected representatives or the government, which is kind of strange, and it's completely un-British in many ways. When in Britain you have one million people marching in the streets, it's anecdotal. It's not going to change anything to the government's or the prime minister's decision, because in Britain, the legitimacy of the power it lays with the parliament was in France with the people so we know we have this power we only need to be you know one million, usually if we were one million in the streets of Paris
我们就会推翻政府的改革或计划。所以我们手中——或者实际上是在我们的脚下——拥有这种不可思议的、不可思议的力量。回到地下世界，你知道的，地下墓穴和下水道，
we will overturn the government's reform or plan so we have this incredible incredible power in our hands reform or plan. So we have this incredible, incredible power in our hands or in our feet, really. And to go back on the sort of underground place, you know, the catacombs and the sewers,
这很有趣，因为在1944年，你知道的，抵抗运动就是从地下墓穴里开展行动的。所以当时有德国人……抵抗运动在地下墓穴中运作。所以你有德国人的坦克，而在距离坦克仅几米的地底下，则有高卢人和20出头的共产党人，他们在那里策划起义。当然还有警察……我们的情况非常不同……警察在法国的形象不太好，因为他们可能会非常迅速地变成恶棍，
it's interesting because during, in 1944, you know, the resistance were operating from the catacombs. So you had the Germans, you know, the resistance were operating from the catacombs. So you had the Germans, you know, tanks and just a few meters below the tanks, you had the Gauls men and the communists in their early 20s, fomenting the insurrection. And, and of course the police we have such different the police doesn't have a very good image in France because they can turn villain
这绝非巧合，拿破仑当时创建了欧洲最高效的警察队伍。斯蒂芬·茨威格（Stefan Zweig）写过一本关于富歇（Fouché）的精彩传记，富歇是拿破仑手下的头号警察头子。这是关于某种意义上的第一位法国警察的最卓越的书籍。所以是的，巴黎总是有些阴暗的成分，
very quickly and it's not a coincidence that Napoleon created the most efficient police in Europe at the time there's a fantastic portrait of Fouché, who was the police head hancho of Napoleon, by Stephen Zweig. It's the most remarkable book about, in a way, the first French policeman. So yes, there's always something murky in Paris,
但也极具吸引力。不过，抗议活动引发了一个一直悬在现代巴黎历史之上的问题，那就是：巴黎与法国。因此，对于许多法国境外的人、对法国历史一无所知的人来说，巴黎某种程度上就代表了法国。但很显然，在法国的故事中，一直都存在着……我的意思是，我们在法国大革命的播客中谈到过旺代（Vendée），谈到过法国大革命期间那种可怕的血腥杀戮。很显然，巴黎历史上的一个重大事件就是1870至1871年的巴黎公社（Commune）。他们输掉了对普鲁士的战争，建立了这样一个左翼政权，然后法国其他地方调转枪头对付他们。是阿道夫·梯也尔（Adolphe Thiers）派军队去镇压他们的吗？这就是巴黎作为一个独立于法国之外的存在的概念。你认为巴黎……这是一个愚蠢的问题，但在某些方面，巴黎就是法国，还是有什么不同呢？
but very attractive too. But the thing about protest raises the issue that's always hung over modern Parisian history, which is Paris versus France. So to a lot of people outside France, people who know nothing of French history, Paris kind of is France. But obviously within the story of France, there's always been, I mean, we talked in our French Revolution podcast about the Vendée and about the hideous kind of
嗯，如果你是雅各宾派（jacobine），巴黎显然就是法国……我还记得我很傲慢……你知道的，当我在90年代末作为一名学生初到英国时，我是一个非常傲慢的年轻法国女性，
bloodletting in the French Revolution. And obviously a big part of Paris's history was the Commune in, what is it, 1870, 71. They've lost the war against Prussia. They set up this sort of left-wing regime, and then the rest of France turns on them. And is it Adolphe Thiers who sends in the army and crushes them? And it's this sense of Paris as something apart from France. Do you think Paris, it's a stupid question, really, but in some ways, isis france or is it something different well if you're jacobine um paris is france obviously um and i remember very arrogant you know i was very arrogant um as a young french woman in in uh in britain in the when i arrived as a student in the late 90s
英国朋友会问：“你来自哪里？”我说：“巴黎，还能是哪里？”这正是我所期望的一个法国学生会说的话，因为你知道的，它是如此中央集权。法国大革命……造就了法国，某种程度上也造就了巴黎，让它成为了今天的样子——如此中央集权。因为它曾经是七零八落的碎片。而那是我们能够凝聚成一个单一民族的唯一方法。语言也是如此。今天，如果有人提出我们可以让布列塔尼语或科西嘉语成为法国学校教授的语言，这在雅各宾派的耳中听起来会非常非常令人震惊，如果你愿意这么想的话，因为这违背了法国作为一个单一民族、一个单一国家的理念。如果你看看欧洲，它实际上是最中央集权的。民族的概念在法国依然非常活跃。所以回答你的问题，在许多方面巴黎就是法国，尽管巴黎公社确实是巴黎的失败，
and people were british friends would say where do you come from and i say paris where else um and that's exactly how i would expect a french student to talk and because you know it's such a centralized the french revolution um made france and in a way paris uh what it is, so centralized. Because it was bits and pieces. And that was the only way that we could make one people. And the same happened to the language. Today, the idea that we could let Breton or Corsican
因为巴黎想要引领潮流、指明方向。他们当时不是吃过动物园里的动物吗？哦，是的。我的曾曾姑妈在公社期间吃过老鼠。但没有吃老虎吧？没有。她只提到过老鼠。我当时还很小，但我记得这个细节。天哪，
be a language taught in French school is sort of very, very shocking to Jacobin ears, if you like, because it goes against the idea of France as one people, one nation. And if you look at Europe, it's actually the most centralized. The concept of nation really is very much alive in France. And so to answer your question, yes, Paris is France in many ways, even though La Commune is really the failure of Paris
这真是一个历史的纽带。但我的意思是，那是一段极其血腥的插曲，对吧？我的意思是，那一定给巴黎留下了非常深刻的伤痕……我的意思是，基本上法国其他地方都调转枪头对付它，许多人被杀害了。这就像脱欧一样。是的。但我的意思是，这一定……你认为可以从那场事件画一条线连到维希以及诸如此类的东西吗？嗯，这非常奇怪，因为当你在……
because Paris wanted to lead the way and show the way. Didn't they eat zoo animals? Oh, yes. My great-great aunt ate rats during the Commune. But not a tiger? No. she only mentioned rats. I was very small, but I remember that detail. Goodness,
你知道的，在法国，我曾是一个左翼学生，我们被灌输了关于巴黎公社的神话，认为那是法国历史上光辉的一幕。而15年之后，当我深入研究巴黎公社的历史时，发现它在各个层面上都是一场巨大的失败。当时共和派、也就是左翼的分裂是极其糟糕的。而实际上，例如第二共和国（1848年至1852年），虽然只维持了四年，但我们至今仍在享受当年拿破仑三世发动政变、先当总统后当皇帝之前通过的许多社会改革带来的福祉。但巴黎公社是一个需要被揭穿的神话，至少在法国是这样，因为我确信你们对它了如指掌，但对我们来说，尤其是……法国的任何左翼人士，他们依然天真地认为公社是历史上的完美典范……你提到了拿破仑三世，我想我记得……可能是在巴黎圣母院的那本书里，你说过关于拿破仑的话……
that's a link with history. But I mean, that's an incredibly bloody episode, isn't it? I mean, that must have left a really deep scar on Paris's... I mean, basically the rest of France turns on it and lots of people are killed. It's like Brexit. Yes. But I mean, that must have been do you think that you can draw a line from that to kind of vichy and all that sort of stuff well it's very strange because when you're
这是一个带有历史渊源的联系。但我的意思是，那是一段极其血腥的插曲，不是吗？我的意思是，那一定给巴黎留下了非常深的伤痕……我的意思是，基本上法国的其他地方都开始反对它，许多人被杀。这就像英国脱欧。是的。但我的意思是，那一定——你认为你能从那画一条线到维希政权之类的东西吗？嗯，这很奇怪，因为当你在
you know in france and i was a left-wing left-wing student we were given that myth of lacrimine being that fantastic episode of French history. And when 15 years later, I plunged into the history of Lacombe, it's just a massive failure on every account. And the division of the Republicans, therefore, of the left wing of the time was abysmal. And when actually, for instance, the Second Republic, 1848 to 1852, it only lasted for four years, but we're still enjoying many of the social reforms that were passed at the time before Napoleon III made a coup and became first the president and then the emperor. But La Commune is such a myth that needs to be debunked, at least in France, because I'm sure you know all about it but for for us especially um anyone on the left in France they they still think naively that Le Camus was that perfection in history um you mentioned Napoleon the third and I think I remember I think it may have been in Notre Dame that you say of Napoleon
你知道在法国，我曾是一名左翼左翼学生，我们被灌输了公社的神话，认为那是法国历史上绝妙的一幕。而15年后，当我深入研究公社的历史时，发现它在方方面面都是一场巨大的失败。因此，共和派的分裂，也就是当时左翼的分裂，是极其糟糕的。而实际上，例如第二共和国（1848年至1852年），虽然只持续了四年，但我们至今仍在享受当时通过的许多社会改革，在那之前拿破仑三世发动政变，先是成为总统，然后成为皇帝。但公社是一个需要被揭穿的神话，至少在法国是这样，因为我确信你们对它了如指掌，但对我们来说，尤其是法国的任何左翼人士，他们依然天真地认为公社是历史上完美无缺的……你提到了拿破仑三世，我记得——我想可能是在《巴黎圣母院》里，你提到拿破仑
the third that actually preferred London to uh to Paris and he spent much of his life in London. And yet he had as much influence as any ruler of Paris has had on the face of the city. And of course, there is one key figure in that history. And we've got a question from Thoughtfully Catholic, who asks, was it a happy coincidence for the regime that Baron Haussmann's reconstruction of Paris made it both easier to move troops and more difficult to construct barricades? So that's what's often said about Haussmann's reforms, that that's the aim. But just more broadly, to what extent do you think Haussmann is personally responsible for the image and the look of Paris to this day? Is he as significant a figure as the myth has him i think he is yes because of the amount of um recreation of paris or or some would say completely destroyed and disfigured and uh destructed paris but um yes the city which you
第三个人其实比起巴黎更喜欢伦敦，他的一生大部分时间都在伦敦度过。然而，他对这座城市的容貌所产生的影响，却不亚于巴黎的任何一位统治者。当然，在那段历史中有一个关键人物。我们收到了“虔诚的天主教徒”（Thoughtfully Catholic）提出的一个问题，他问道：“男爵奥斯曼对巴黎的重建，使其既便于军队调动，又更难构筑街垒，这对政权来说是一个幸运的巧合吗？”这往往是人们对奥斯曼改革的看法，认为这就是其目的。但从更广泛的意义上讲，你认为奥斯曼对至今仍存在的巴黎形象和外观负有多大程度的个人责任？他真的如神话般那么重要吗？我认为是的，因为巴黎有大量的重建工作——或者有些人会说巴黎被彻底摧毁、面目全非、遭到破坏——但是，是的，这个城市你
which you mentioned as being full of people and basically he's the guy who who clears it doesn't he completely i mean basically he's's the man chosen. He was the prefect of Bordeaux. And Napoleon III, who didn't like Paris so much. And that's why he could decide on such radical redesign of the French capital. Otherwise, he would have never dared doing what he did. And he chose Haussmann for his efficiency. He was a workaholic. He would come to his office at 6 a.m. And he was very talented as well. And the thing is, he still carries this sick, sick body that needed a surgeon. And he told Hausmann, look, I want Paris to breathe. I mean, we're
你提到这个城市到处都是人，基本上他就是那个进行清理的人，对吧？完全是这样。我的意思是，他基本上就是被选中那个人。他曾是波尔多的省长。而拿破仑三世并不那么喜欢巴黎。正因如此，他才能对法国首都进行如此激进的重新设计。否则，他永远不敢做他所做的事。他选择奥斯曼是因为他的效率。他是个工作狂。他早上六点就会来到办公室。而且他也非常有才华。问题是，他当时还带着这个需要外科医生动手术的病入膏肓的身体。他对奥斯曼说：“听着，我希望巴黎能呼吸。”我的意思是，我们
also talking, I mean, it did great things in terms of hygiene, because Paris was this place with cholera, for instance, in 1832, 20,000 Parisians died of cholera. You had pockets of, I mean, it was so insalubrious. And the Ile de la Cité even itself, although it was a gem of medieval lanes and it hadn't so much changed since the Middle Ages, but it was also a haven of prostitution and criminality and disease. So Haussmann just cut like a surgeon and made those big, you know, arteries where people, Parisians were very happy.
也在讨论，我的意思是，它在卫生方面做得很好，因为巴黎曾经是个霍乱横行的地方，例如在1832年，有两万名巴黎人死于霍乱。你到处都能看到贫民窟，我的意思是，那里太不卫生了。甚至西岱岛本身，尽管它是中世纪小巷的一颗明珠，自中世纪以来并没有太大改变，但它也是藏污纳垢、犯罪和疾病滋生的避风港。所以奥斯曼就像外科医生一样大刀阔斧地切开，修筑了那些宽阔的、你知道的干道，让巴黎人感到非常高兴。
They had this huge boulevard. They had this beautiful urban design, which we still have somehow, I mean, in some parts of Paris. And he gave it the look that we so cherish today. So, you know, every Parisian is in two minds about Hausmann, because so much was lost, so many hôtels particuliers, so, you know, gems on the Boulevard Saint-Germain on both sides of the river, really. But on the other hand, he also gave all these boulevards with this uniform
他们有了这条巨大的林荫大道。他们有了这种美丽的城市设计，某种程度上我们今天依然保留着，我是说在巴黎的某些部分。他赋予了我们今天如此珍视的面貌。所以，你知道的，每个巴黎人对奥斯曼都抱有复杂的感情，因为失去了太多东西，失去了那么多的私人宅邸，失去了塞纳河两岸圣日耳曼大道上的那些明珠。但另一方面，他也留下了所有这些拥有统一
looking buildings, all the same with their maids' rooms on the 6th and 7th floor, this sort of bourgeois, but also, you know, there was gas and electricity and water uh and the sewers too i mean they had started we love sewers but you know each time there was a head
外观建筑的林荫大道，它们都长一个样，6楼和7楼都有女佣房，这种资产阶级的风格，而且还有煤气、电、水，还有下水道——我是说他们已经开始……我们热爱下水道，但你知道，每当有国家
of state visiting paris they wanted to have a visit of sewers uh because it was such you know state of arts uh sewers so know, he was a great guy and he destroyed a lot of Paris. So do you think, I mean, basically, that is then what sets the stage for what I guess most people outside France would think of as Paris's golden age, which is the Belle Epoque.
元首访问巴黎时，他们都想参观下水道，因为那是如此先进的下水道。所以你看，他是个了不起的人，但也毁了巴黎的很多地方。那么你认为，从根本上说，这就是为大多数法国以外的人所认为的巴黎黄金时代——也就是“美好年代”——奠定基础的原因吗？
And when, you know, the era where Paris is the centre of the world. And you've got Proust and Picasso and Toulouse-Lautrec. I was going to ask a question which, well, Thoughtfully Catholic has asked another question, which I think is a really good question, because this is the Paris of Émile Zola. And it's the Paris of the kind of classic 19th century,
也就是巴黎成为世界中心的那个时代。那里有普鲁斯特、毕加索和图卢兹-劳特累克。我本来想问一个问题——好吧，“虔诚的天主教徒”又问了一个问题，我觉得这是一个非常好的问题，因为这是埃米尔·左拉的巴黎。这是那种经典的19世纪、
late 19th century French novels. I mean, I loved, when I was a student, I had this mad idea of reading all Zola's Rujon macar sequence and completely nuttily failed but um you know that portrait of paris there is kind of late 19th century paris and that's the one that is enshrined i think in the world's imagination i think it's a bit later i think it's i think it's the kind of the the paris of of proust and no i don't know i despise that paris i'm all about that i'm all about the late 19th century Paris. I'm the Paris of La Somoire and all these sort of...
19世纪末的法国小说的巴黎。我的意思是，我喜欢，当我还是个学生的时候，我有一个疯狂的想法，那就是阅读左拉所有的《卢贡-马卡尔家族》系列小说，结果彻底惨败了，但是……你知道，对巴黎的那个描绘，那种19世纪末的巴黎，我认为它已经铭刻在世界的想象中了。我觉得要稍微晚一点，我觉得那是……普鲁斯特的巴黎，不，我不知道，我鄙视那个巴黎，我全心全意关注的都是19世纪末的巴黎。我是《小酒馆》和所有这些类型的……
It's a massive Zola-Proust punch-up. It is. Zola would win that punch. I mean, Zola, God, a mighty course. I mean, Proust would just retire to his room. He would, but they would. The noise. But also the Dreyfus case. The Dreyfus case.
这是一场左拉与普鲁斯特的史诗级大战。确实是。左拉会赢得这场对决。我的意思是，左拉，天哪，当然了。我的意思是，普鲁斯特只会退缩到他的房间里。他会这样，但他们会……那种喧嚣。还有德雷福斯事件。德雷福斯事件。
I mean, Paris is sort of convulsed by that, isn't it, Agnes? and sometimes generations don't talk to each other. And of course it's different, but not in the way it has set people against each other, I think. And yes, the Dreyfus Affair is a defining moment of modern France. So the Dreyfus affair is when this Jewish officer is accused, falsely accused of espionage. He's sent off his knee to Devil's Island. And it's clearly that he's been framed. There's anti-Semitism.
我的意思是，巴黎因之而陷入动荡，不是吗，阿涅斯？有时不同世代之间甚至无法对话。当然情况有所不同，但我认为并不是以那种让人们彼此对立的方式。是的，德雷福斯事件是现代法国的一个决定性时刻。所以德雷福斯事件是指这位犹太军官被指控、被虚假指控犯有间谍罪。他被流放到了魔鬼岛。很明显他是被诬陷的。这里面存在反犹太主义。
He's been supposedly passing secrets to the Germans. And then it turns into this colossal scandal because they cover it up, don't they? And in a way, can you not sort of trace that all the way? And Zola sends in j'accuse jacques exactly and gets in such trouble that he he has to go into exile in upper norwood fate worse than death and objects to the quality of the pastry in upper norwood which i don't think he's very grateful is that really true yeah yeah well i mean pastry i i've mentioned my fact about ho chi minh training under supposedly training under
据说他一直在向德国人泄密。然后这演变成了一场巨大的丑闻，因为他们掩盖了真相，不是吗？从某种意义上说，你难道不能一路追溯到这一点吗？左拉发表了《我控诉》（J'accuse）——雅克，没错——并陷入了巨大的麻烦，以至于他不得不流亡到上诺伍德（Upper Norwood），这命运比死还难受，而且他对上诺伍德的糕点质量提出异议，我觉得他一点也不感恩。这是真的吗？是的，好吧，我的意思是，糕点——我之前提到过胡志明据称曾在
le scoffier as a pastry chef. So pastry is obviously woven through French history. Yeah, well, he went to Upper Norwood and he complained they overboiled the fish and the pastry was inedible. Well, he had food poisoning, you see. Don't think it shows much gratitude, really, for the hospitality of Upper Norwood. But then I guess we're into the World Wars, aren't we? When Paris is a city, I so in world war one the germans
勒科尔菲（Le Scoffier）师从糕点师的轶事。所以糕点显然贯穿了法国历史。是的，好吧，他去了上诺伍德，抱怨他们的鱼煮得太老，糕点也难以下咽。好吧，他食物中毒了，你看。我觉得这确实没表现出对上诺伍德好客之情的多少感激。但我想接下来我们就进入世界大战了，不是吗？当时巴黎是一座……在第一次世界大战中，德国人
kind of almost get there but they're stopped on the marne by the taxi drivers of paris who kind of you know all set off and carried the soldiers to the front and then of course paris almost falls in the first world war and then it does fall in the second world war but obviously that everyone's seen those pictures of a the the germans sort they're on horseback, aren't they? They're riding down the Champs-Élysées. And there's also the famous images of people sobbing in the streets. And the sense in which Paris, which is this sort of sacred centre of France, has fallen actually in the most humiliating way to the foreign invader. That's what Casablanca is about.
差不多要攻占那里了，但他们在马恩河被巴黎的出租车司机拦住了，他们出发把士兵运送到前线，然后当然，巴黎在第一次世界大战中几乎沦陷，接着它在第二次世界大战中确实沦陷了。但显然每个人都见过那些照片：德国人骑着马，对吧？他们骑马沿着香榭丽舍大街前进。还有那些人们在街头痛哭的著名照片。巴黎作为法国某种神圣中心的地位，实际上以最屈辱的方式向外国侵略者沦陷了。这就是《卡萨布兰卡》的主题。
The whole of Casablanca, in a sense, is a kind of... A lament. A lament for the occupation of Paris. It's interesting because, in a way, the fall of Paris really defined, again, no other city was more powerful. And the fall of Paris represented
整个《卡萨布兰卡》从某种意义上说就是一种……一种哀歌。对巴黎被占领的哀歌。这很有趣，因为从某种意义上说，巴黎的沦陷确实再次定义了——没有其他哪个城市比它更有影响力。巴黎的沦陷代表了
the fall of Western civilisation. Nobody talks about the fall of Brussels, do they? I mean, well, the Belgians do, but nobody else does. But also, likewise, the liberation of Paris was... And that's where Notre Dame comes in again. Yes, that was this moment of pure elation, not only for Paris, but for the whole world. This is, in a way, you know, there are wonderful moments
西方文明的沦陷。没有人会谈论布鲁塞尔的沦陷，对吧？我的意思是，好吧，比利时人会，但没别人会。但同样地，巴黎的解放也是……这就是巴黎圣母院再次登场的时候。是的，那是一个纯粹狂喜的时刻，不仅对巴黎，而且对全世界都是如此。从某种意义上说，你知道，有一些美妙的时刻，
because Paris was not going to be liberated by the Allies because, you know, as I know, it was not a strategic... Is it Leclerc? Leclerc. It's the dash. Yes. So basically, at some point, you know, in Normandy, as the invasion, or as we call it in France, you know, in Normandy, as the invasion
因为巴黎将不会由盟军解放，因为，正如我所知，这不是一个战略……是勒克莱尔吗？勒克莱尔。那是突击。是的。所以基本上，在某个时刻，你知道，在诺曼底，当入侵——或者我们在法国所说的，你知道，在诺曼底，当入侵
or as we call it in France, you know, the debarquement is happening, the American troops are not going to go via Paris because it's not strategic. They have to make their way as fast as possible towards the east. And de Gaulle
或者我们在法国所说的，你知道，登陆战（débarquement）正在发生时，美军不会经由巴黎，因为这不是战略重点。他们必须以最快的速度向东推进。而戴高乐
says, look, guys, we need to liberate Paris. And de Gaulle says, look, guys, we need to liberate Paris. And so he has this very heated conversation with Aizano. And of course, the Free French are under command of the Americans. I mean, they can't go, otherwise they will face, you know, a martial court. But because it's so important, Leclerc, who is under the command of Général de Gaulle,
说：“听着，伙计们，我们需要解放巴黎。”戴高乐说：“听着，伙计们，我们需要解放巴黎。”因此，他和艾森豪威尔进行了非常激烈的交谈。当然，自由法国军队是在美国人的指挥下。我的意思是，他们不能擅自行动，否则他们将面临军事法庭的审判。但因为这件事太重要了，在戴高乐将军指挥下的勒克莱尔，
actually sends a vanguard. And he faces, really, I mean, it could have been a trial and been a march on court, but he sends a vanguard. And at the same time, the resistance in Paris have launched their own insurrection. And there are some very dangerous moments when the Parisians don't have anything to eat. They obviously, I mean, the resistance can do what they can. But also, I mean, adding to the jeopardy is the fact that Hitler has ordered the governor of
实际上派出了一个先锋队。他确实面临着——我的意思是，这本可能是一场审判并面临军事法庭的审判，但他还是派出了先锋队。与此同时，巴黎的抵抗力量已经发起了他们自己的起义。有一些非常危险的时刻，巴黎人没有任何食物。显而易见，抵抗力量尽其所能。但除此之外，危险雪上加霜的是，希特勒已经下令
Paris to basically blow it up. He has instructions to destroy the city rather than abandon it. It's the most dramatic, hair-raising narrative. And then it has this kind of wonderful climax where the governor doesn't blow up Paris. The Allies join with the Free French in capturing it. Hemingway gets drunk and General de Gaulle walks into Notre Dame and there is no one better to tell us the story of what then happens than you. Go on, give us a patriotic French thrill.
巴黎的守军基本上将其炸毁。他有指示要摧毁这座城市而不是放弃它。这是最戏剧性、最令人毛骨悚然的故事。然后它迎来了一个美妙的高潮：守军并没有炸毁巴黎。盟军与自由法国会师并占领了它。海明威喝醉了，戴高乐将军走进了巴黎圣母院，没有人比你更适合给我们讲述接下来发生的故事了。来吧，给我们带来一种爱国主义的法国式惊悚。
But Hemingway, before he gets drunk at the Ritz, you know what he does? He goes to Shakespeare and Company to say hello to the wonderful ladies there. And he also calls on his friend Pablo Picasso. But Pablo is not there. But the concierge of Picasso says, do you want to leave a note? So he goes back to his Jeep and he takes hand grenades and he leaves a few hand grenades with a note to Picasso. And then he goes to the Ritz. Okay, now fast forward 26th of August 1944. General de Gaulle has arrived.
但在海明威在丽兹酒店喝醉之前，你知道他做了什么吗？他去了莎士比亚书店向那里伟大的女士们问好。他还去拜访了他的朋友巴勃罗·毕加索。但巴勃罗不在。不过毕加索的看门人问：“你想留个便条吗？”于是他回到吉普车上，拿了几颗手榴弹，给毕加索留了几颗手榴弹和一张便条。然后他去了丽兹酒店。好了，现在快进到1944年8月26日。戴高乐将军已经抵达。
There are still German snipers in the streets of Paris. I mean, it's still quite a dangerous place, but obviously the Leclercc, the Free French and the Americans have moved in. And so that's how the whole day has been conceived. And the radio tells, the French radio tells Parisians and the French that de Gaulle is going to walk down the Champs-Élysées. So two million people in the streets of Paris to acclaim that man they've never seen really. They might have seen the picture, might have listened to him on the BBC, but they've never met him. So he goes down the Champs-Élysées. At the Place de la Concorde, there are far too many people, so he has to hop on a car that drives him through Rue de Rivoli, passes the Louvre. He goes to Hôtel de Ville, where he inspects the troops and the communist resistance and the Free French all together. And Washington and London and all the film operators are there. And Washington and London are looking very keenly to see whether de Gaulle is really the man, because they don't
巴黎街头仍然有德国狙击兵。我的意思是，这里仍然是一个相当危险的地方，但显然勒克莱尔、自由法国和美军已经进驻了。这就是整天行程的构思方式。广播告诉——法国广播电台告诉巴黎人和法国人，戴高乐将沿着香榭丽舍大街步行前进。因此，两百万人涌上巴黎街头，欢呼迎接那个他们从未真正见过的男人。他们可能见过他的照片，可能在BBC上听过他的声音，但他们从未见过他。于是他沿着香榭丽舍大街前进。在协和广场，人实在太多了，所以他不得不跳上一辆汽车，车子载着他穿过里沃利街，经过卢浮宫。他前往市政厅，在那里检阅了部队、共产主义抵抗力量和自由法国军队。华盛顿、伦敦和所有的摄像机都在那里。华盛顿和伦敦都在敏锐地观察戴高乐是否真的是那个真命天子，因为他们还
know yet. And whether he can tame all those unruly communist resistance. This is really what they are afraid of, especially Washington. And de Gaulle being de Gaulle and being a French man, he says, I need to end with a mass, a tedium at Notre Dame. So he walks from the Hotel de Ville in this sea of people. And he just passes the porch, the entrance of Notre Dame, when snipers within the cathedral starts shooting. And imagine, there are about 10,000 people who have been waiting for de Gaulle to enter. They've been sitting on the pews everywhere, waiting for that great liberator. And so how Brex loseos, and we have this audio document that I really urge people to listen to. You can. It's accessible online.
不知道。以及他是否能够驯服所有那些桀骜不驯的共产主义抵抗力量。这确实是他们害怕的，尤其是华盛顿。而戴高乐作为戴高乐，作为一个法国人，他说：“我需要在巴黎圣母院以一场弥撒、一场感恩赞美诗来结束。”于是他从市政厅步行穿过这片人海。他刚走到巴黎圣母院的门廊入口处，大教堂内的狙击手就开始开枪了。想象一下，大约有一万人一直在等待戴高乐进入。他们坐在各处的长椅上，等待着那位伟大的解放者。结果一片混乱，我们有这段音频资料，我强烈敦促大家去听听。你可以听到的。它可以在网上获取。
There's this young guy, he's 27. His name is Raymond Marciac. It's his first live reportage for French radio. He's lying on his belly with all his equipment on the upper gallery. And we listen to all this. And we hear so much fire and the bullets ricketing on the pillars and, you know, such a brouhaha. And so he describes the scene saying that people are just crouching
有个年轻人，他27岁。他的名字叫雷蒙·马西亚克（Raymond Marciac）。这是他为法国广播电台做的第一次现场报道。他趴在上层看廊的肚皮上，所有的设备都在身边。我们听到了这一切。我们听到密集的枪声和子弹在柱子上的反弹声，还有那样的喧嚣。因此他描述了当时的场景，说人们只是蹲下
and hiding behind pillars and under the pews. And de Gaulle is just walking tall at a slow pace. Bullets are just whizzing. And he goes up the altar. And it's very funny because de Gaulle talks about this moment, obviously, in his memoirs. And he says, well, I had to be very calm so that people don't panic because the last thing we needed was a panic of 10,000 people in that Gothic cathedral.
并躲在柱子后面和长椅底下。而戴高乐只是昂首挺胸、以缓慢的步伐向前走着。子弹就在耳边呼啸。他走上了圣坛。非常有趣的是，戴高乐在回忆录中显然谈到了这一刻，他说：“嗯，我必须非常冷静，这样人们才不会恐慌，因为我们最不需要的就是在一座哥特式大教堂里发生一万人的恐慌。”
And he keeps it to 12 minutes, basically, because there are a lot of people being injured outside on the square. A 12-minute mass? Yes. That's Father Ted, isn't it? It was a magnificent. And you can hear it in that audio reportage. It's magnificent. And so he stands up and he walks slowly.
他基本上把时间控制在12分钟，因为外面广场上有很多人受伤。12分钟的弥撒？是的。那是《伯父特德》（Father Ted）的风格，对吧？那是一场壮丽的弥撒。你可以在那段音频报道中听到。它太壮丽了。于是他站起身来，缓缓走开。
And it's quite extraordinary because he could have been shot there. It was an assassination attempt. And he just has a word with Leclerc and says, you know, clean up the place for me, please. But to this day, we don't know who those snipers were, whether they were German, collaborateur, or perhaps communist. Because the communists really didn't want, really, de Gaulle as the French leaders, the French new leader. But luckily, de Gaulle managed to tame the communists. And then after the war, do you think that was Paris's last kind of golden age, the age of the left bank and existentialists going up to, I don't know,
这相当非同寻常，因为他当时可能会中枪。这是一次暗杀未遂。他只是跟勒克莱尔交待了一句，说：“你知道的，请帮我清理一下这个地方。”但直到今天，我们仍然不知道那些狙击手是谁，他们是德国人、合作者，还是可能是共产主义者。因为共产主义者真的不希望戴高乐成为法国的领导人、法国的新领导人。但幸运的是，戴高乐设法驯服了共产主义者。然后战后，你认为那是巴黎最后的黄金时代吗？左岸的时代，存在主义者出没的时代，一直到，我不知道，
1968. And that was the kind of Paris's last moment in the sun, as it were, internationally. Oh, yes, I think so. Well, first of all, because everybody still at the time could read French or understand French. So it means that they didn't need to be read in translation or they were translated. Whereas today, you don't understand French intellectuals when they speak and you don't read them because they are not translated. But having said that, I'm not sure that's true because I think that the influence of of um paris intellectuals it remains incredibly strong i mean certainly in america but not as strong as it was in the 50s though i think i think more so i think i think the influence of fuko and derrida is that's only in universities though tom yeah only in universities but we've discussed culture wars and we've seen you know
1968年。那是巴黎在国际上最后的辉煌时刻，可以这么说。哦，是的，我想是的。好吧，首先，因为当时每个人都还能阅读法语或理解法语。这意味着他们不需要通过翻译来阅读，或者说它们已经被翻译了。然而今天，当法国知识分子说话时你听不懂，而且你也不读他们的作品，因为它们没有被翻译。话虽如此，我不敢确定这是真的，因为我认为法国知识分子的影响力
this reverberates outwards and the irony is is... You can buy posters of Albert Camus. No one can buy... You can't buy a poster of Jack Derrida. Because he's safe and dead. Whereas Foucault and Derrida, I mean, essentially, it's their influence on America that people in Paris
仍然强得惊人——我的意思是，当然在美国是这样，尽管没有50年代那么强烈。但我认为——更有甚者，我认为福柯和德里达的影响力……那只是在大学里，汤姆。是的，只在大学里，但我们讨论过文化战争，我们看到
are now complaining about. You're right. You know, that's the paradox of it. And we would say today that it's because all those American students didn't understand a thing, Derrida and Foucault, because deconstruction doesn't mean demolition and doesn't mean consolation. And so something was lost in translation here but yes we're suffering today of the terrible misinterpretation of of the french thinkers by american students but i think that's another podcast le blowback well i think on that note and yes i can't thank you enough that the whistle stopped all through the history of of the great city
这向外扩散，而讽刺的是……你可以买到阿尔贝·加缪的海报。没有人能买到……你买不到雅克·德里达的海报。因为他是安全的、死去的哲学家。然而福柯和德里达——我的意思是，本质上，他们在美国的影响力正是巴黎人现在所抱怨的。你说得对。你知道，这就是其中的悖论。我们会说，今天之所以这样，是因为所有那些美国学生根本没有搞懂德里达和福柯，因为解构并不意味着拆除，也不意味着安慰。因此，这里在翻译中有些东西失真了，是的，我们今天正在遭受美国学生对法国思想家的可怕曲解之苦。但我想这是另一期播客“回弹效应”（the blowback）的内容了。好吧，关于这一点，是的，我非常感谢你对这座伟大城市历史的闪电式回顾。
thank you so much we never cleared up the urinating in the streets though Tom I think that's another podcast isn't it yeah right we should yeah merci
非常感谢，不过我们始终没有澄清在街头随地小便的问题，汤姆。我想那是另一期播客的内容了，对吧？是的，没错，我们应该……谢谢。
merci beaucoup pas du tout merci bye everybody we'll see you next time. Thanks for listening to the Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢，不客气，谢谢大家，我们下期见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要收听独家分集、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。